dieser fliegende soldat war am
diesjährigen nationalfeiertag vermutlich
der höhepunkt bei der militärparade in
paris wurde technisches militär
equipment vorgestellt dazu gehörten
drohnen autonome kleinstfahrzeuge
soldaten mit drohnen abwehrwaffen und
eben auch der scheinbar frei fliegende
soldat
das mit düsenantrieb funktionierende fly
bord kann bis zu 190 km h schnell
fliegen und wurde durch die finanzierung
des militärs von erfinder frankie zapata
entwickelt lokalen medien wollte
präsidentin manuel makro die
diesjährigen feierlichkeiten auch im
zeichen des europäischen zusammenhalts
in militärischen angelegenheiten
verstanden wissen neben bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel gehörten zahlreiche
weitere europäische
führungspersönlichkeiten zu den
geladenen gästen am vorabend des
nationalfeiertags hatte makro
angekündigt noch im september ein
militärisches weltraum kommando starten
zu wollen